mystique en ouverture de séance pour en
parler j'accueille ici hervé marseille
bonjour bonjour est le président du
groupe centriste au sénat on a entendu
gérard larcher dire qu'au nom du
sénateur entier il souhaitait condamné
avec la plus grande solennité cet acte
de guerre intolérable qui met en péril
la sécurité du continent il a exprimé un
sa société au peuple ukrainien
injustement agressée un mot sur ces mots
forts c'était important de montrer une
solidarité comme cela avec l'ukraine est
aussi fait qu'il ya une unanimité du
parlement absolument dans des moments
aussi
préoccupant aussi difficile parce que
maintenant
une fois encore depuis longtemps nous
avons la guerre en europe nous avons la
guerre en europe et il est normal il est
important de marquer la solidarité de
l'ensemble des groupes avec la
population ukrainienne du gouvernement
ukrainien mais le maquereau qui a pris
la parole à 13 heures il a promis que la
france et ses alliés décideront de
sanctions trop là aussi à la hauteur je
cite de l'agression elle se rend
coupable et qui porteront sur le plan
militaire et économique autant que sur
le domaine de l'énergie ces mots sont
impressionnants notamment parce que le
mot militaire qui a été prononcé par le
chef de l'état vous l'avez entendu à 13
heures oui j'ai entendu le chef de
l'état il faut reconnaître que le
président
de la russie monsieur poutine s'est
jouée de nous sait jouer également de
monsieur macron
les occidentaux ont cherché le dialogue
ils ont cherché les voies de la paix et
la réponse a été la guerre celle qui a
été déclenchée par monsieur poutine on
est aux portes de l'europe on est aux
portes de l'otan et à l'évidence on est
dans une situation extrêmement grave
préoccupante et qui peut déraper à tout
moment il parle de sanctions je vous le
redis 1 qui porteront sur le plan
militaire ça peut signifier que des
soldats de l'otan des soldats avec
peut-être des troupes françaises pour
être projeté sur ce terrain là ils y
sont déjà nous avons des soldats cela a
été annoncé il ya quelques semaines en
roumanie et les forces de l'otan vont
être renforcés renforcer dans ces pays
notamment nevers les pays baltes car il
faut s'attendre à tout de la part de la
russie est à l'évidence l'otan va devoir
manifester la plus grande vigilance à
l'égard d'
de l'action des russes dans ce dans ce
secteur c'est le message que vous
porterez notamment demain puisque il ya
un comité de liaison parlementaire qui
est réuni à matignon avec les chefs de
file de tous les groupes politiques du
parlement ainsi que la ministre désarmer
les milices affaires étrangères et le
chef d'état major des armées c'est une
bonne nouvelle que l'exécutif que le
prix ministre prenne tout de suite le
temps de recueillir et 2 d'avoir la
parole des chefs de file politiques du
parlement je crois que c'est légitime il
est normal le président de la république
et le chef des armées c'est lui qui mène
aussi la diplomatie du pays on a vu
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'efforts qui ont
été déployés il ya une situation de
guerre et il est pertinent que
évidemment la représentation nationale
soit informée que nous puissions poser
nos questions de taux puissions nous
tenir informés
et avoir des cet échange avec l'exécutif
c'est un moment important et vous nous
l'annoncer il y aura bien un débat au
titre de l'article 50-1 la constitution
comme l'avait demandé beaucoup de
groupes politiques de ce matin à
l'ouverture des séances vous nous
l'annoncer ça va avoir lieu la semaine
prochaine oui va d'abord et y avoir
également
ce qu'on appelle un article 18 c'est à
dire la lecture d'une déclaration
solennelle
du chef de l'état demain il peut pas
venir donc du coup il fait lire un
message voilà le droit de venir
donc simultanément à l'assemblée au
sénat la lecture dans les deux chambres
simultanément de ce message du chef de
l'état c'est une procédure assez rare
qui est très peu usité c'est dire que la
situation est importante la semaine
prochaine par une conférence des
présidents mardi à 14h30 et puis il y
aura ce débat au titre de l'article 50-1
la constitution ce qu'on vient de faire
sur le sahel on va le faire sur la et
l'ukraine c'est à dire un échange une
déclaration des parlementaires vis-à-vis
de l'exécutif sans vote bien entendu à
l'issue du débat un dernier mot il nous
reste une minute car le scénario est
pendant deux jours la conférence
interparlementaire pour la politique de
sécurité et de défense commune ans et
tous les drapeaux que l'on voit derrière
vous aurez marseille s'est donc organisé
ici alors c'est une coïncidence mais
c'est aussi un moment peut-être où il va
y avoir quelque chose de très fort qui
peut se jouer pendant deux jours ici au
sénat oui je crois que c'est important
qu'ils aient cette réunion le hasard
fait que c'est en cette période si
mouvementée c'est un moment des changes
c'est important encore une fois que les
parlementaires et les parlements soit
associée à ce qui se passe en ce moment
parce que ça concerne l'ensemble des
français
[Musique]